we are focusing most of our energy not
on financial re-engineering cuz that's
not what's been troubled at Apple we're
focusing our energy on the right product
strategies the right Market strategies
the right communication strategies the
right logistics and distribution
strategies I'm pretty committed to this
and seeing Apple turn around the company
I mean it's I started the company with
Steve wnc in my parents garage you know
20 years ago and over 22 years ago and
so there's a definite place in my heart
for this uh I'm drawing a salary of I I
think a dollar per year so uh I hope I'm
not burdening the shareholders too much
and I very much want to see apple get
turned around and I think it's going to
so I I don't know how much more
committed I could be if people need
these symbols well maybe that'll happen
I don't know but you know my answer to
them is I don't know how I could be
working any
[Music]
harder